objections it is so decided
the end of the road after two weeks and
countless sleepless nights these were
negotiations with a draining intensity
may i just say to all uh delegates
i apologize for
the way this process has unfolded
and
i'm deeply sorry
i also understand the the deep
disappointment
but i think as you have noted
it's also vital that we um protect this
package
code red no planet b this was
effectively an emergency meeting for our
world to keep 1.5 alive did it deliver
what's just been gaveled through is
literally a betrayal of people and it's
a little betrayal of the science it's
betrayal of the realities of the climate
impacts are happening and devastating
people's lives and livelihoods the only
people celebrating this outcome are the
hundreds of lobbyists from the oil and
gas industry those whose vested
interests basically say you know we
can't see any change we can't move away
from the fossil fuel addiction of our
economy the glasgow climate pact was
nearly derailed at the last minute as
india south africa and china demanded
last minute amendments wanting the
wording on coal to be changed to phase
down instead of phase out
this brought anger from small island
states this commitment on coal had been
a bright spot in this package
it was one of the things we were hoping
to carry out of here and back home with
pride and it hurts deeply
to see that bright spot dim and the
pressure of two weeks of negotiations
finally told on the cop president alex
sharma
away from the nitty-gritty of
negotiations a raft of big announcements
were made hoping to shape the outcome of
cop26
on forests more than 100 countries
pledged to end and reverse deforestation
by 2030 bankrolling
billion dollars to do it
another 100 countries pledged to cut 30
percent of highly toxic methane
emissions by 2030.
it was declared the end of coal is in
sight as more than 40 countries
committed to shift away from the fossil
fuel
on finance corporations controlling 40
percent of global assets pledged to
align themselves to the target of a 1.5
degree celsius warming limit
and the rabbit out of the hat us and
china surprising delegates with a
declaration that vowed to boost
cooperation between the world's biggest
emitters
but many say all that just means nothing
unless nations act on their promises
as the usual suspects blocked progress
in the talks nations like saudi arabia
russia and australia the voice on the
streets was loud and angry
[Music]
this is no longer a climate conference
this is now a global north greenwash
festival
phasing out fossil fuels and climate
finance were both major stumbling blocks
to consensus in the negotiations
themselves
and the bid to get countries to up their
commitments every year as opposed to
every five years
and so the process that began with the
paris agreement in 2015 continues
but the urgency for action grows with
each passing day
the next u.n climate conference will be
held in sharma sheikh in egypt in a year
in the meantime will the pledges be
honoured will the promises be kept will
countries return with greater ambition
because one thing is certain
time is running out
nick clark al jazeera glasgow